our OMI this may not be the term that is
bandied about inside your organization
is certainly not a term that is been
deed about in the industry but it's
actually the one that you want to use so
let me explain what is in it for you to
measure this this actually begins to
position you not as the company's next
CMO it may position you as the company's
next CEO because guess what the CFO is
not the top of the food chain and the
CFO has generally been asking for the
wrong thing for years this is the right
thing to demonstrate this is the
calculation you want to do this puts you
in a powerful position first of all you
shift the conversation you basically put
yourself in a position of convincing
generally it's the CFO that you
understand finance as well as he or she
does and you know must CFOs aren't
expecting that from somebody in
marketing you know you know they tend to
look down on us where we're merely the
expense you know that they have to
deduct somewhere along the way in their
financial calculations okay fine but
here's the deal ROI is the wrong metric
the CFO may ask for it because the CFO
is used to asking for it for other kinds
of things like capital expenditures if
you're going to do a capital expenditure
like building a new factory or a plant
are you going to stock a lot of
inventory someplace that's a capital
expenditure or what is known as camp
X
and trust me if you are a publicly
traded company some investor out there
some industry analyst is going to want
to know about your capex it's something
you're going to have to report on a
quarterly basis so trust me the CFO
focused on it but that kind of money is
tied up when you make that kind of
investment it's generally a long-term
one and you may depreciate it but you
know what that's why everyone sort of
focused on it it turns out marketing is
not a capital expenditure marketing is
an expense you generally expense it over
the course of a quarter you know we
spent some money this month on who knows
advertising content marketing people so
on the blank and if it is an operational
expenditure then it is called up X and
if you want to measure the impact of
what you're doing in marketing you know
you end up using a very different
formula then your CFO has been asking
for for years but here's the deal when
you look across the table and say
actually you're asking for the wrong
thing what you really want is our OMI
not ROI in yeah I do know how to
calculate that a return on marketing
investment is basically the incremental
revenue that you can attribute to your
marketing so you know we've been
measuring goals or micro goals and you
can measure those in revenue because you
know what the lead is that you brought
in and what it's worth and you know what
the sales you brought in on what they're
worth or you you certainly know what
percentage of those leads tend to
convert the sales and therefore you
you've got a a figures of what your
sales pipeline may be valued at guess
what you can calculate that and then
here's the magic you go beyond revenue a
lot of people would stop there and say
wow that's an impressive thing I've
never reported revenue before aren't ia
hero now but if you take the next step
and you say and also I know what
dobutsu margin is a lot of people will
call that your profit margin in other
words when you raise revenue there's
still a cost of goods sold you know take
some money to manufacture your product
or it takes some money you know the e
for the people you have to pay to
deliver your service and when you're all
done paying you know the cost of goods
sold what's left is your profit and that
is a percentage of your revenue and if
you multiply the revenue that you bought
in times the profit margin so some
percentage of that is going to turn into
profit and then you subtract what you
spent on your content marketing campaign
and divide by what you spent on your
content marketing campaign you come up
with a number
it's your are omi and let me give you an
example just to sort of bring this home
let's say for example that you spent
$100,000 on a content marketing program
and it delivered five hundred thousand
dollars in incremental revenue that you
have been able to track and say didn't
come in from outer space you know here's
the campaign we ran we generated this
and oh by the way the contribution
margin for that five hundred thousand in
revenue was let's say 60% any word said
took about 40% to cover the cost of
goods sold but the profits on top of
that were 60% where does that number
come from
it's a mythical number but you know it's
going to vary in different organization
so I'm just using it here to teach you
the math but I'm going to measure my
results by taking that 500,000
multiplying by 60% because I want to get
to the profit number and then I'm going
to subtract a hundred thousand that I
spent and divide by the hundred thousand
and I get the number two and you're
going to say I've never heard this
number before and the answer is neither
has your CFO but here's what it means
for every dollar that you spent on
content marketing you generated two
dollars in profit not revenue you
generated $5 and revenue you generated
two dollars in profit now do you want to
do a little more content marketing next
quarter let me tell you anything that is
a positive number is a good result if
you can get anything north of 1 you're
breaking even
hey once I become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simple
learn Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here